the worst moment for our business came
when we were
the the company was generating 28 29
million dollars
that year and we almost lost the
business because even
success can destroy a company and what
we were dealing with at that moment is
success was destroying our company
well well it was only a matter of time
before this happened
my friend co-founder co-ceo and most
importantly the god king of the daily
wire jeremy boring
moved to la as a young man with stars in
his eyes 20 years ago and now
we are in the midst of pulling our
thriving business out of this garbage
state for a new home
before this company jeremy hustled
around hollywood for a long time he
became good friends with people who'd go
on to have big careers all the while
working for his own big break he did
some acting he wrote and pitched movies
around town
he produced several of them at
production companies he started with his
buddies over the years
he even ran the inconspicuous
organization friends of ape a group
formed to bring together the people on
the right working throughout hollywood
it was through this group jeremy and i
met we knew early on we'd do business
together
we thought we struck gold with our first
venture but that went bust when jeremy
was abruptly fired
which is okay because it led us to
create the daily wire you'll hear the
full
epic jeremy ben origin story here today
we'll also discuss the man that moved
jeremy to conservatism and the big plans
for daily wire when we touch down
in nashville tennessee
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special just a
reminder
we'll be doing some bonus questions at
the end with jeremy boring and the only
way to get access to that part of the
conversation is to become a member
head on over to dailywire.com become a
member you'll have access to all of the
full conversations with every one of our
awesome
guests jeremy boring thanks so much for
joining the show i mean you literally
just came down and now we're talking
yeah like i own that and that
it's good to be here so yeah this is
this is kind of weird i mean it's it's a
weird setup
we talk literally hours a day and now
we're going to talk in front of a camera
so we can't say any of the things we
would say off camera because we're on
camera
so why don't we it's also weird because
i don't know which questions to ask you
since i know so many of the answers
already so why don't we start with how
did jeremy boring grow up
you know texan boy slate in texas
explain the upbringing of jeremy boring
media mogul
yeah so like uh like all media moguls i
come from humble beginnings
i was born in a small town in west texas
called slaton population of about
six seven thousand something like that
and uh
my dad's a railroader mom stay-at-home
mom and
you know it's a it's a wonderful town it
isn't really known for much i mean
peggy sue from the buddy holly song
peggy sue i think was born there and
uh bobby keys was born there and other
than that like if you
a very funny thing that happened to me
is my dad called and said
you know i was just on the slayton
wikipedia town and you're like a notable
person in the uh that'll tell you just
how uh
how prominent is the town of slaton you
know it's a great town it's a
wonderful people very um there's sort of
a divide in town between
german catholics and then baptist that's
what the town is german catholics and
baptists and
uh we have um like all small towns you
know it's very
very patriotic pro-america it's texas so
it's very pro-texas
and you know i'm i'm pleased to have
gotten the
childhood that i got you know it was
before the internet i'm part of that
weird generation where when i was 18 is
when everything happened like
at 18 i got a computer at 18 i got a
cell phone at 18 i got an email address
what that means is i got to have an
entire childhood without those things
and so you know you'd still be gone for
two or three hours a day on your bike
and your parents wouldn't know where you
were
and there are other people looking after
you and i think that kind of
is something that's been lost now is
that you know parents always know where
their children are
at all times the child never has to face
any kind of adversity
on their own you never have to learn to
make decisions for yourself you know
when you're
off with your pals and you're not under
the watchful eye of a parent
people get hurt you know and people make
mistakes and you actually have to solve
for those mistakes even as a young
person and so i'm pleased to be sort of
that last generation i think where that
was true
and then how did you end up moving from
slate in texas to
l.a like well yeah so you got the the
hollywood bug
well as much as i love it as much as i
love my hometown and i truly do
i hated that place when i was a team you
know it's uh
for all the good that comes from small
town living you know for
a guy like me i was looking at the
horizon uh my entire youth you know i
was wondering what was on the other side
and and you know manifest destiny go
west young man i had some great
opportunities
at a very young age when i was you know
in first grade i met my childhood best
friend todd
and his father ran the local
entertainment scene and when i say that
you might say how could there be a local
entertainment scene in the town of six
thousand
well it's because we're very close to a
somewhat larger town called lubbock
texas
you know which was they call it the hub
city because it really is the hub of
that entire part of the state
and a lot of prominent in particular
musicians came out of lubbock buddy
holly
natalie mains of the dixie chicks in
fact natalie's father
lloyd maynes and todd's father don had a
recording studio together
where a bunch of sort of texas country
acts joe ely
the mains brothers those sort of people
sort of came up playing and recording
their early albums in
the studio that don owned and so that
just afforded todd and i a ton of
opportunities we didn't
we didn't know how lucky we were at the
time
when i was a little bit older you know i
maybe was 11 12
i went to see a play at a nearby
regional theater called the garza
theater to see
don's daughter caldwell's daughter cami
in a play
and when it was over my dad was always
sort of interested in introducing me to
people and
a local morning show host on the biggest
country radio station in that part of
the state which of course means
the biggest station in that part of the
state uh jane prince jones was running
the theater at that time and my dad
i didn't know that he didn't know her
because he just walked up to her with
sheer confidence and said jane i want to
introduce you to my son
and she was frazzled and harried and
she said uh do you have any theatrical
background no she goes
would you ever be interested i said sure
she said okay and then she
tornadoed away and yeah i probably would
have never imagined that she even
remembered that that conversation
happened
until a few weeks later my phone rang
and it was this
local celebrity asking me if i wanted to
come be a part of this theater
and do you know learn how to do lights
and sound and that sort of thing
and that really was sort of the next
step you're growing up around
the caldwells and all that musical
background then getting the opportunity
to engage in the theater
and then a few years after that don
opened a theater in lubbock which is a
little bit bigger than the garza
and so you know by the time i was 16 17
18 todd and i were producing
you know sizable shows for for certainly
for our age and for that
area you know had the opportunity to
produce and direct the buddy holly story
for the buddy holly music festival in
lubbock and you we had a 40 or 50
000 budget which you can imagine in that
part of the country at that time
given the fact that i was 17 or 18 years
old was a really big deal and so
we we both just grew up with so many
opportunities to engage in the arts and
we both had our eyes on the horizon
i went west todd went east he's in uh
brooklyn and plays hammond b3 for like
crosby stills nash and
all these big musical artists and i came
out here and just failed consistently
for 20 years and i met you
so it's interesting because i actually
didn't know until this moment that you
had like a production background
really and because when you came out to
hollywood you weren't really looking to
get into production per se you're you're
more looking to get into acting now
it took moving to la and and only a few
months of being in la to realize
that i'm not an actor you know one of
the
beautiful things about the lubbock art
scene is it was
big enough that it provided opportunity
but small enough
that those opportunities were available
to people like me who were just kids and
not particularly experienced and so i
had a lot of opportunities to act
uh in the theater scene in lubbock and
and
people were gracious with me the other
actors
i think that what i thought at the time
is that i was learning to be
an actor and what i was really learning
was to be a producer
because one thing that happens when
you're when you're doing entertainment
in a low budget environment is you're
constantly having to solve
problems that if you had money money
would be the solution
and and both jane and don really
invested in me and helped me understand
uh you know how do you make it happen no
matter what sort of the show must goes
on kind of a
mentality so i got to hollywood you know
stars in my eyes thinking that i could
be an actor i had a really early break
i did background work which is you know
where you're an extra
the the actors up here and you're back
here moving your mouth as though you're
saying words but you're not allowed to
make a sound so you're about
like this uh and the very first day that
i did
background work when i first got to la
desperately poor
no money you know living in the worst
apartment in the worst part of town
where you would hear
well i tell people it's absolutely true
my apartment was here there was a
parking lot here where
a mcdonald's and a strip club called the
classy lady shared the parking lot
and so you know like two o'clock in the
morning you stumble out of the strip
club you go get yourself some mcnuggets
and you try not to get shot you'd hear
gunshots like three or four times a week
no joke
because i you know i was poor and i also
hadn't learned you know la
for all of its opportunities kind of a
shabby town yes you know yes
and at that time i couldn't discern the
levels of shabbiness
so now like you know the part of town
that we're in it's shabby but it's like
shabby chic
but i couldn't have told you at that
time the difference between ventura
boulevard and
the part of town i was in which i won't
name when i got my first day
total poverty first opportunity go be an
extra and they're gonna pay like 50
bucks you know to stand in the
background
and i got to set that morning and you
can't make this up it was a
film i believe james spader was starring
in it about the american revolution
and day one they've got like 150 extras
out there for these battle scenes
and it's early in the morning six in the
morning or something and the director
walks out
and he says does anyone here have any
experience shooting a gun
almost no one did but texas guy all
right so i raised my hand
he said okay so i want you to go over
and work with the effects team
and they had you know they had these uh
black powder rifles and they needed us
to be up in the hills
to load the flash pan and to shoot the
rifles you know and so i was like but
this is awesome i got a bump to like 75
dollars instead of 50 dollars yes i was
pretty excited and
then lunch time comes along i spent the
whole morning up on this hill
you know flashing black powder out of
these out of these
muskets and not rifles they were muskets
and then lunch time we go and you get to
eat for free which at that point was a
pretty big
plus for me and then the director came
and he he looked very upset and he said
does anybody here know how to pray i'm
not making this up my very first
job in l.a american revolution does
anybody know how to shoot a gun
does anybody know how to pray and once
again i raised my hand
and the director said come with me and
he said uh
there's keep in mind people were just
getting cell phones right at this time
and we're way out
up the five so we're outside of town on
this production ranch
no cell service anyway and he said we we
cast a guy
for a roll and he has a small scene now
which is
in the middle of the film he has another
scene where he has lines which is
earlier in the film but gets shot later
because film's not shot uh consecutive
you know chronologically he said and we
can't reach him he was supposed to be
here at six this morning he's still not
here
you know i don't have cell service up
here i don't know if he has a cell phone
we've been trying to get him
he said but you know the show must go on
which was a mentality i unders
i understood he said what happens in the
previous part of the
the film he's the son of one of the main
characters in the film
and he expresses that he is a patriot
he's going to go fight and his father
tries to talk him out of it
he says in this scene he sees the lines
of redcoats coming over the hill for the
first time
and we're coming across the line of
colonials and we stop on him and we see
him react
to you know sure death and he says a
prayer
he says we want you to ad-lib the prayer
because none of us know anything about
prayer
and i said that's great so i now i have
a part in a movie right day one
just like something out of out of a you
know fantasy out of
a novel and sure enough they put makeup
on me and the camera comes by and it
stops on me and i
i see the red coats coming of course
there are no red coats and i s and i say
a prayer
and for that reason now i'm taft
heartlead into the screen actors guild
i didn't get paid fifty dollars for the
day i didn't get paid 75 dollars for the
day i got paid like
500 for the day and uh
and then the movie fell apart two weeks
later the other scene was never shot
and the film never came out because
hollywood turns every single victory
into a defeat
i mean they were i don't know a million
two million four million dollars into
this film
the whole thing collapsed but it created
a great opportunity for me
which is that from then on i could do
background work and make like two three
four hundred bucks a day which is how i
survived those first couple of years
that and and
the generosity of strangers uh and
friends is how i survived those first
couple of years after that though i got
a couple auditions and very quickly
realize that
there are people who are good at being
actors and then there are people who
suck at being actors
and i was not in the former category an
actor has a unique ability to live
in the moment when people talk about it
you know that guy has
it he has star quality what what they're
really talking about they may not even
consciously know it
but they're talking about two things one
is how much space you occupy
i mean physical space stars take up a
lot of room
and two they completely live in the
moment and you see this because we're
around a lot of stars even political
stars
you could say to to dennis prager who
takes up half of this room
you could say to dennis prager dennis at
the end of this hallway
there is a publisher's clearinghouse
size check
for one million dollars i would like to
give it to you
he'd be very happy about that now we
have to walk down the hall so that you
can receive it
dennis would be incapable of getting to
the end of that hall
without stopping in this room and
talking to the hair and makeup people
then stopping in this room and getting
fully invested in the life of you know
the animator
and then he'd walk back to the harem
makeup person because he had another
thought
that might benefit them because stars
have that ability
to just live perfectly here even though
the mill you know the other thing
i don't have that ability i'm a producer
i'm always thinking about
how do we get dennis prager down the
hall so that we can get the million
dollars
and so that made me a terrible actor
which was revealed in a humiliating way
when i got an audition and they asked me
to do the the devo robot dance
and i didn't know what that was and i
ad-libbed something and they laughed at
me and i never tried to act a kid
so i want to get into your sort of
peripatetic
forrest gump like career in hollywood in
just one second
but first let's talk about protecting
your data social media companies they
get to decide what content is suitable
for these sensitive snowflakes among us
and they censor whatever they don't like
literally they will shadow ban it or
they'll prevent you from seeing it
shouldn't you be the one to decide what
you want to read or watch not them
well here's one thing you can control
their access to your data and for that i
use expressvpn
see the problem with big tech companies
is that they not only censor what you
read but they actually track what you do
online
they track what you're searching for the
videos you watch everything you click
they then use that data to serve you ads
they can match your activity to your
offline identity
using your device's unique ip address
when i use expressvpn tech companies can
no longer see my ip address at all my
identity is masked and anonymized by a
secure vpn server plus
expressvpn will also encrypt 100 of your
data to protect you from hackers and
internet bad guys
if that sounds complicated it isn't i
promise expressvpn software takes just
one minute to set up on your computer or
phone you tap one button you are now
protected so
why give the tech companies a free
license to know everything about you and
then monetize all of it it is your data
take back your privacy today at
expressvpn.com
ben by visiting my special link you get
an extra three months of expressvpn
service for free
who doesn't like to save money again
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
expressvpn.com to protect your data
today
alrighty so now you're in hollywood
you've decided that you can't be
an actor but that doesn't end the
hollywood dream for you on account of i
suck
right but it doesn't end the hollywood
dream for you no no no you just end up
being sort of the guy who stands next to
a bunch of very famous people
for a prolonged period of time so what
what is that period before i left
lubbock i had written a play with a
friend of mine named lee higginbotham
who moved out
to la with me and i really enjoyed the
process of writing it
and so now i'm you know i'm poor and uh
not much is going on i was here for one
year exactly almost to the day
and 9 11 happened and like everyone i
was really rocked
by that event i went to sort of an
existential crisis of of identity and of
religious faith
you know who am i what do i believe what
do i stand for
it lasted for two three months after
that where i really didn't leave my
apartment much
i was in probably the deepest depression
of my life and
i was questioning the resurrection and
trying to understand the resurrection
uh why the resurrection i kind of
understood
the idea of why there needed to be a
sacrifice for sin i couldn't quite
understand
all right so why did the sacrifice get
to come back
and i worked that question out for
myself over that period of time
when i merged the other side of that i
really had no more desire to be an actor
and what i had on my hand was a lot of
time and so i thought well i'm going to
go back to this writing idea and
i wrote a tv pilot at that time called
elijah
in that period of time i i met my first
kind of people in l.a i'd been here for
a little over a year maybe
a year and a half and was starting to
meet people and
a wonderful family sort of took me under
their their wing i was working with a
manager at that time
as an actor and now i didn't want to act
anymore and he had someone
helping him run his management company
and she wanted to start an acting agency
her husband is one of the top comedic
writers in town
you think of the biggest comedies over
the last 20 years
he's been one of the ringers on those
shows from
from matt about you frasier all the way
to
30 rock and modern family i mean
whatever the biggest comedy of the at
the time it's him
and so she asked me if i would help her
sort of as an assistant get her agency
off the ground
and that was really good for me because
well a gave me a little money and b it
got me out of my apartment out of this
funk
and getting now i was actually meeting
people in la and starting to build
community
and sort of like jane and don had done
in lubbock
this family really invested in me and
when i wrote my
pilot elijah i i gave it to my boss
because i didn't know who else
to give something like that to and she
took it to her husband which was
i mean incredibly generous ever
everybody wants a guy like that to read
their stuff right here i am just some
punk
22 23 year old kid and he read it he
and he liked it and he shared it with
his agents uh who were
you know endeavor before the william
morris endeavor merger one of the big
tv agents in town somebody i had no
business talking to
right but he also liked it and he
brought me in for a series of meetings
and that really built my confidence i
think and helped me
realize that there could be like a
post-acting la
life for me and so from that period of
time you know i read every script i
could get
again having the the relationship with
that family gave me access to a lot of
it
he would just send me scripts and let me
read them and
and i would write and during that period
of time i started to meet the people who
would be my la
community a friend of mine moved out
from lubbock and he started attending a
men's bible study
and it had all these like young kind of
up-and-coming celebrities in it
and he would not let me go to it he was
like no these are my friends
i made it you didn't make it uh you're
on your own
but one day this young uh he was he was
over at the home of one of these people
and he asked me if i'd come give him a
ride
so i went over in my little nissan
pickup and i picked him up
and this young actor named joel moore
came out
and he had a trail which was like the
precursor to the blackberry it was a
phone with a keyboard you know and he
was typing on it and
you know being a hollywood guy and he
glanced over at my
pickup truck sitting in his driveway he
said hey is that your truck
i mean i'm sitting in the driver's seat
yes he said uh huh all right
and that was it that was my kind of my
first minor celebrity interaction in l.a
you know
a couple weeks later he called that guy
calls me off at that same trail and he
says
hey you still got that pickup truck i
mean yeah it's been two weeks and i'm
poor i don't
there are no new cars coming
he said you want to help me move a couch
and now this is one of my secrets that
you know now i like to help people
become successful
one of my secrets is if you live in a
big city drive a truck
everyone needs help all the time i mean
you'll be sitting like in the
in the best buy parking lot and there
will be a knock on your window this
actually happened to me twice
and i look over and there's just some
stranger in my window it's like uh
hey i just bought a washing machine you
think you could help me
you know i don't want to pay for the
shipping and then you know you do it
and you meet people so i went over and
helped joel move this sofa and he said
hey stick around for the bible study
and i mostly wanted to do it to see the
look on my buddy's face when i got
invited without him you know
and uh i walked in and and that would
that group of men became my community uh
really for
for all these last you know 15 18 i've
been in la 20 years now
and from that period on that was my
community and it was guys who
had energy you know they they were
working they were all at kind of
different stages in their career but
almost everyone who was there that night
has gone on to have success and that's
another great lesson for people on
how to become successful is you know
surround yourself
people will often say you know surround
yourself with successful people
and that's true if you can i actually
think it's more important to surround
yourself with people who are going to be
successful
right people who have have a mentality
for success an appetite for success
people who know things that you don't
know that group of men we went through
you know life and death together
throughout our 20s and
early 30s and everyone's gone on to do
great things
um and and we all were invested in each
other and
and so i had a a skill at that time well
two
one i knew a little something about the
new testament so i was able to
help lead that bible study over time and
two
i could write and no one else had really
stumbled into that yet
and so both of the actors in the group
who were you know beginning to have
prominent careers
uh gave me the opportunity to write with
them and they could actually do
something with the scripts that i
couldn't do
and so in 2005 that culminated in
getting to make my first feature film
which was called spiral star joel
a young actor named zachary levi who's
gone on to have a wonderful career
in amber tamblyn it was a basically a
three-person film
and at that point i realized
you know we had this amazing opportunity
to make a feature film
and you know that's a multi-year run so
that represents four years probably of
my life
and to realize that the entertainment
business is just a business
and a lot of the lessons that i learned
i think in that period of time have
borne fruit for us even here at the
daily wire all these years later
so how did you make the move from sort
of hollywood hollywood
to conservative hollywood yeah it's not
quite the same thing as we have
found out multiple times well no
hollywood hollywood pays conservative
hollywood
does not check true you know during the
george w bush administration
with that group of men who i was getting
the opportunity to kind of come of age
with
because i had this sort of pastoral role
in the community
you know i also engaged with with the
guys on worldview on broader worldview
and
i would always sort of be arguing the
conservative points of view
i had become a conservative because i
went to college for two years you know
i'm very anti-college
but i went to college for two years at a
at a junior college in level and texas
that has a commercial music program they
literally teach you how to play
bluegrass so they teach you how to play
and a bunch of country stars have gone
through there again natalie maines of
the dixie chicks leanne womack
uh several others over the years and
while i was there i had this professor
who was ostensibly supposed to teach me
how to play
the piano if you've ever heard me play
the piano you know that he failed
mightily at his job
but i had this private lesson with him
twice a week and we would argue about
politics and religion
and he was very libertarian he would
hand out copies of
these books by uh richard mayberry
called
whatever happened to penny candy and
whatever happened to justice
which are sort of easy libertarian
tracts you know and
um i disagreed with almost all of his
philosophy and i would argue with him
and i i never realized that he was
winning the arguments
until i got a couple years down the road
got to la and realized that i was taking
his position
instead of the position that i had
formerly had and so
you know in that way he really helped me
discover my beliefs and now i was trying
to help these guys
you know refine some of their beliefs
and as a result
everyone knew that i was very
conservative you know one of my
buddies at that time was on a sitcom on
abc
which is great because the rest of us
were dirt poor and you could go over
there and eat for free
you know craft service on a film set or
a tv set is amazing there's just
constant food and
catered meals so i would go over and
we'd play halo up in this dressing room
and then i would like hide water bottles
in my pocket
and i had a bush cheney 2004 bumper
sticker at that time on my truck
and i would park right behind his sort
of supercar on the lot
and one day i'm walking up the stairs
you know with like i mean peanuts and
bottled water a turkey leg
all hidden under my coat and this
wonderful actress you know who i had
grown up watching on a show with my
father and
was really kind of star struck and
probably love truck by
sees me coming up the stairs and she
says hey uh
real quick is that your pickup that
parks right behind and i said yeah yeah
she was
you're aware that there's a bush cheney
bumper sticker on the back of your truck
oh yeah yeah it's i put it there she
goes oh
you got balls of steel kid
and until she said it i honestly didn't
know i was too naive
to know that you just can't do that in
this town
and sort of like when you learn a new
word you hear the new word everywhere
i started hearing all the bias now all
around me all the time
how political is a film set how
political is a television set
how the number one topic of conversation
on film and television sets is
politics and that may sound obvious now
because in the
in the trump era everything is so
political
it but the world had not yet become
political only hollywood was political
like this at the time
and i realized pretty early on that
that was gonna create problems for me
because i
am just too ornery and probably too
stupid to
play along you know i've i've got that
texas streak in me where i
i say what i think and you know damn the
torpedoes kind of a thing
several things happened during that
period of time i had developed a tv show
with that actor
for eric mccormick's production company
big cattle and
and we took it out william morris took
it out for us and
um and we got some good traction with it
and we were in a
meeting i won't say who it was it'd be
inappropriate and
i still harbor some dreams of one day
you know making a film again so this was
one of the most five most powerful
people probably in hollywood 10 most
powerful people in hollywood who we got
a pitch meeting with
and we go into his office and over his
desk
is a life-size photo of him with
president clinton
so you know right where you stand right
and he's surrounded by these two female
executives you know
one of them his you know comedy
development exec and
some other executive in his company and
we're doing our song and dance you know
and
then he comes down and then the talking
dog and you know we've got it all
figured out and all of our jokes
and he's not listening to us a bit he's
too good for these meetings and he and
he was too good for these meetings it
was courtesy for the actor right
he's flipping through our script not
even reading it finally stops everything
he says
who's the babe
uh what do you mean the babe who you got
in mind for the babe
uh the actress uh you know we're
thinking about this actress with her
name and he said no no no no i've
already
what is he being figurative is he being
no i've already
cause i i need somebody that i haven't
uh how about
this actress and he threw out the name
of another very prominent actor he goes
now that's somebody i'd like to then he
looks over at his female comedy
executive and he says i mean
face it if you were a man you'd you'd
probably
or anyway and i thought it was a real
revelatory moment for me right
then the the executive says oh yeah
i probably would anyway ah and they they
had a laugh about it
i thought holy crap if this were any
other industry in the world like
if this were walmart tomorrow it would
be called stephanie mart like she would
own the joint right but i realized in
that moment that
none of the normal rules that apply to
propriety and business apply in
hollywood because you know
this woman is probably 32 33 years old
at the time
probably has a law degree from harvard
probably could have gone to a law firm
and got 280 000
right out of college instead she
probably went and worked in the mail
room at caa for sub minimum wage
was abused horribly by uh powerful
people for five years that she worked
her way out of that
she got her first job at a network got
abused horribly again
making very little money worked her way
up clawed and scraped
because she's on a path to actual power
in the culture and she's not about
to cash all of that in for a 500 000
settlement from this tv studio a million
dollar settlement from this tv studio
no way she didn't go through all of she
could have made five million dollars
in her career she had just gotten that
law job right out of
she's chasing something greater and for
that reason
this guy has complete impunity to treat
her in any way that he wants to
and that's when the reality of what
hollywood is really started to hit me
and i started kind of not know what to
do with that information and i retreated
back into myself a little bit
as i had all those years earlier after 9
and and get lost i was also hungry and
desperate i wanted to succeed
i was starting to get resentful of my
friends who were succeeding which is a
terrible sign when you can't be happy
for your friends
you've got a little bit of a cancer and
i was confused i didn't know what to do
and another another friend of mine who
attended the home study
at that time the bible study uh who was
the heir to a very famous
business family you know as as rich and
powerful as you can be
and political uh invited me
to this secret hollywood meeting of
conservatives called friends of abe yes
commander you've got it he called me
commander he's larger he's got it
takes up a lot of room lives in the
moment it's a commander you've got to
come to this
meeting you know they think the way you
think they say the kind of stuff you say
and we went he was kind enough to take
me to one of these things
and uh he's gone on to be a huge movie
star since and probably
has evolved different political opinions
than he had when he was a kid
but i was like lucky enough that the
opinions he had at the kid led me to
this organization
and i met all these underground
hollywood conservatives
this was getting close to 2008 and i
just realized like i
i could have a voice in things that were
important to me
in politics that i couldn't have if i
kept pursuing culture
at that first meeting andrew breitbart
was there bill whittle was there our
buddy johnny voigt was there
so a lot of people it became sort of my
next phase of my you know
the second half of my hollywood life the
people who were very important to me
and really because of that meeting i got
to meet you so we'll get to that in a
second that transformational moment
and finally we met and that's right and
the dream was was truly launched we'll
get to that in just one second but first
let's talk about
your sleep quality there's nobody on the
planet like you so why would you buy a
generic mattress built for everyone else
helix sleep they've got a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
whether you're a side sleeper hot
sleeper whether you like a plusher from
bed with helix there's no more confusion
and no more compromising
helix sleep is rated the number one
mattress by gq and wired magazine
cnn called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just head
on over to helixsleep.com take their two
minutes sleep quiz they will match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life they've
got a 10 year warranty you get to try it
out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but indeed
you will how do i know because i have a
helix sleep mattress my wife and i
took that sleep quiz we have a mattress
personalized to us it is fantastic
i require a mattress made just for me
because after all i have kids who wake
me up every five minutes
helix right now is offering up to two
hundred dollars off all mattress orders
for our listeners get up to 200 bucks
off at helixsleep.com again that's
helixsleep.com
check out helixsleep.com for 200 off
okay so now you're working for friends
of abe
and this is pretty close to when we met
so i believe we met in 2010
correct that's right i think it's 2010
so i wasn't working for friends of abe
at the time i was just attending right i
was a
just a guy looking for community and
exploring my political beliefs in a more
urgent way
the election was going on in 2008 and
one of the great
moments of my hollywood life i started
having
jon voight bill whittle and andrew
breitbart
i was living with with this actor at the
time right who was successful
uh and was kind enough to let me lodge
and
on thursday nights i would get those
those guys would come over to my
to my well wasn't my house
and and we would talk about ways that we
could
engage with politics and i made my first
political video at that time
uh which was about obama's attendance of
of uh reverend wright's church in
chicago was called a thousand sundays
which was more or less the number of
sundays that he had spent listening to
to black liberation theology this is
before pj tv
events before bill whittle has a
political career and
one day at that time i was producing
this this little film
um and i was helping do a re-edit of the
original cut of the film
and we had set it up in the living room
of this house on the actor's big screen
tv
we'd set up this whole uh editing rig
and i was you know just trying to help
these guys get their film where it
needed to be
there's a there's a knock at the door
and one of the
young filmmakers you know who had made
this very inexpensive but very charming
little film
goes and answers the door and he comes
back and his eyes are like saucers and
he says
john voight is at the door he asked for
you
and i you know i hopped up and i went
over the door and it was john i said
john
what's going on he says i want to bring
you these materials lad about john
mccain i was like oh thank you i'd love
to watch him he gave me some dvds
and he looks over he goes oh you lads
are working
i didn't mean to interrupt could i get
you you boys some sandwiches
to my to my living shame to this day
i said ah john that's nice no we already
ate
now ten years later i'm just like why
didn't you let john voigt buy you a
sandwich
always let john boy buy you a sandwich
that's another important life lesson let
john boy buy you a sandwich
so friends of abe was giving me these
these cool opportunities cool
experiences
and and a few years after that
is when they came to me and asked me if
i would take it over and run it
the founder wanted to step away he was
doing some very important
philanthropy at the time that he wanted
to focus his attention on
and and i got to spend the next five
years leading that organization
but right there in the middle was that
fateful day
when when ben shapiro and jeremy boring
first met
yeah so again a lot of this is a
tributal from my angle to andrew
breitbart because i end up getting a job
at out of law school i joined a law firm
and i'm working there for 10 months i
hate it i quit
and now oca room for you yeah no no no
no uh
and i am unemployed and newly married
and i have a mortgage
and i talked to my friend andrew
breitbart who i've known since i was 16
years old and i was at ucla
and andrew says you know there's this
guy named mark masters he runs a company
called talk radio network and he may be
looking for an in-house council
so why don't you go talk to him so i
talked to mark and i end up getting
a job for one-third the pay doing some
in-house counsel work but the deal was i
would only do
law half the time and then the other
half of the time i'd be doing production
work like literally just cutting audio
for various radios and
putting together articles and
highlighting parts of them and and
making sure that all these hosts were
prepped
for for the day and over time i see that
mark has
hollywood aspirations like mark wants to
make movies and he's particularly
enchanted with the folks over at what a
workshop in new zealand
and one day he says to me you know
there's this guy i know from friends of
abe who really knows the movie industry
and i think that you should talk to him
because you're writing at that point i
was writing a book called primetime
propaganda about
about propaganda inside the the tv
industry and the leftist bias of the tv
industry
and mark said you know you really should
talk to this guy jeremy boring
and i'll be honest at the time i was
like okay i'm not sure what we're
talking about exactly but
sounds okay and also you know i'm
writing a book on tv and i have a little
bit of chip on my shoulder and i'm like
okay i guess i guess we'll we'll talk
and
he hooks us up to talk about the
possibility of movies and you're walking
me
through my my first recollection is you
walking me through the industry and
basically saying there's no money here
and it's hell and me thinking well
patented speech right exactly
a speech i've heard you now give many
many times and me thinking
how am i supposed to go back to mark
with this exactly because mark's big
aspiration was of course to get into the
industry
right but yeah that was kind of my point
of view i don't know how it was for
for you yeah so i actually don't
remember
i remember us meeting i don't remember
exactly the pitch from mark
so like you andrew breitbart came to me
and said hey i've got this
this guy you should know named mark
masters he runs at that time i think the
largest private
uh talk radio syndication company in the
country up in oregon and he has film
aspirations
and he's i think it'd be good if he
heard your your perspective
and so you know i had a couple of
meetings with mark i really liked him
he's a
you know he's he's a big thinker and a
big dreamer
mark and and very philosophical so i i i
really enjoyed visiting with him and
talking to him
and he wanted you know i had been to
weta had been to new zealand
at that time because joel had shot the
film avatar
out there which because of a weird
way that the world works i got to go out
for part of that
and so i remember mark wanted us to meet
but i don't there was some sort of
actual deal that he wanted us to connect
about i feel like
and i've i've tried for a couple years
now to remember what that deal was i
don't
but what i remember is that you and i
got together at a coffee bean
on ventura boulevard and we had this
conversation and i
tried to dissuade you from wasting
mark's money trying to get into
traditional hollywood
uh into a traditional hollywood deal
what i remember being particularly
struck by was a couple things one
that you were the smartest guy i'd ever
talked to
two i'd never really been around anyone
who was from right i've never been
around
not a lot of jews and slayton yeah not a
lot of jesus there was one but he was
definitely reformed
i'm in a tangent for a minute to tell
you about this guy he was my
he was my high school vice principal and
his name was bill jolly he passed away
very recently
wonderful man he was like dennis prager
size like
six foot six 300 plus pounds a jo
and you look for smooth stones whenever
the guy came around you know
he he had some sort of weird chromosomal
genetic thing where he had a big bushy
mustache and half of it was snow white
and half of it was jet black divided
right down the middle
and he loved life and he loved his
students and he was
jewish and and practicing jewish you
know not not not in name only
although not orthodox but he took his
judaism very seriously there was
one synagogue in in i think
only one in lubbock at the time and he
took me there one time as my first
really exposure
to judaism and he he gave me
this is an absolutely true story i had
gotten drunk for the first time
uh on some on some red boxed red wine
which was my go-to at that time
and everybody knew it you know uh
todd's mom knew it because she knew the
people that i was there with from the
theater
and i she asked me about it and i lied
to her you know because i was a stupid
idiot kid
and then bill jolly knew it i'm sure you
could just see it all over me you know
and he asked me about it and i lied to
him too as though
as though hungover barely getting
through his day
you know 17 year old jeremy was smarter
than these actual humans who had lived
live you know these actual adult humans
but he he listened to me pleading my
case for why
i was still a good boy and he gave me
this great piece of advice he was
scottish background a scottish jew
and he said jeremy i'll give you a great
piece of advice i said
if you're going to drink drink scotch
this is my high school vice principal
right and i said well mr jolly
why he says well scotch is very
expensive jeremy and i know you son
and you will never be able to afford to
be an alcoholic
about which it turns out he was wrong
yeah exactly now you can actually afford
all the scotch i can afford all the
expensive scotch i'm i'm essentially a
teetotaler i mean i
yeah i probably drink three or four
glasses of alcohol a year
but only the most expensive whiskey
that's the only thing exactly
so we finally yeah so we finally meet
yeah yeah
and i don't have a lot of memory of that
of what happened in that first couple of
weeks but i remember fairly soon after
that
that i was at your condo and
you were showing me production stuff
that you had done
on your laptop you had made some videos
uh stuff that some of it you had done
for mark some of it you had done for
yourself and it was sort of conceptual
and you handed me a couple of
screenplays that you had written to
one of them they were for tv they
weren't filmed
and i read them and thought i mean ben
is very
very intelligent by my standards very
successful at that time
you owned something like a piece of
property
and and actually talented and
knowledgeable and i i thought at that
time like
this guy is going to be a friend and i
think that we're going to do some stuff
together i mean we started working
together pretty quickly i mean we
started thinking about at that time you
were doing something called declaration
entertainment
right and we started talking about you
know 10 videos that you could produce
and we it was mostly us talking business
strategy
and kind of throwing around ideas for
really several years there we did kind
of little side projects
we made those videos for encounter
encounter books so for for
people who who know encounter books is a
really great publisher and one of the
first things that
that i did is i realized jeremy had
these gifts visually and
in terms of production that i didn't
have and that he really needed sort of a
pitch man to put him in the room
with people who needed to do those kinds
of videos because at the time you were
doing bill whittle's videos but
i thought okay me doing more production
videos so for no margin at all
you were doing these these videos for
for
encounter books and and then you started
doing videos for
prageru on the back of that right and
that became kind of a business
for you i was working with jonathan haye
who
became our head of production here at at
daily wire when we first started right
he
he helped kind of create the look of
those prager videos and helped create
the look of those early encounter
videos i had i had one employee
essentially right it was i had a little
business the business was me
i actually had two employees because
technically bill was an employee of the
company
and jonathan and poor jonathan had been
working on american idol before
i drug him into this and making an
actual adult salary and now he was
getting paid like
i don't know 28 000 a year bill whittle
was actually getting all the money
because he
you know he was the talent and i was
making like 12 000
a year for three four years at that time
yep
one of the things that actually occurs
to me in this conversation is you
actually
you actually saw an opportunity in me
first and it was these small
opportunities to do this visual
content and then later i started to see
an opportunity
for you but it is kind of funny i always
think about the second part of that
story because it's the one where all the
success came from
but the first part of the story is
central to it which is you out of some
sort of
uh altruism or something wanted me to
have opportunities
i saw a talented guy and i saw that the
talent you're kind of spinning your
wheels and so it was like i wanted to
make sure i
as as behind the scenes i have quoted
many times for for me
a key principle is uh hyman roth i
always make money for my friends and so
[Laughter]
quoting the elderly jewish gangster from
the godfather who ends up very poorly
but in any case the
the we started working together and then
sort of the first time that we formally
worked together where we actually formed
a company together
and we actually started working together
was with truth revolt and this is now
circa 2013.
yeah so you had given me one of the best
pieces of business advice
i ever got and at the same time another
friend of mine
named frank gave me a very similar piece
of advice and it was sort of
you know god wanted me to hear it twice
you you said it much more colorfully
than he did
which is you said something along the
lines of
jeremy you're you're very good at
pissing
but you are very bad at knowing which
way the wind blows
you if you would just turn and let
reality
work for you instead of you always
working against reality
i think you'd have some success and that
really resonated with me
at that time i was also realizing
something about you which was that you
needed to be famous
and that you needed a platform from
which to influence
the political conversation and i thought
that i had discovered it
because again by way of andrew breitbart
and some of our
friends of a connections i'd become pals
with a lot of the board members at the
david horowitz freedom center
david former leftist becomes
conservative
and i saw a lot of commonality between
you and david
both fighters you know not not
both highly intellectual both great
writers but fundamentally fighters not
not think tank guys both jewish
both part of the la scene both with a
with a rich interest in culture the
difference of course being that he's 50
years older than you are
and i i could see that there was going
to come a time where david would need to
step down
and he would want his legacy the freedom
center to be passed on i thought well
there isn't a better guy in the country
than ben for that job
so behind the scenes i started meeting
with board members who are also part of
friends of abe
and planting seeds about this and
getting buy-in and this goes on for
maybe 18 months
of really getting people to see that you
could be the future of
of the freedom center and then they were
working
david uh behind the scenes until one day
and this is the way all good ideas are
right one day it's david's idea
not not mine that you could be the heir
at the freedom center and he calls you
and gives you this opportunity
with truth revolt and you and i at that
time create
yeah to your point we created our first
company within
within the freedom center within the
freedom center and it actually saw some
initial
pretty significant success and we
learned some really important lessons
from that one
among those lessons were luck is not a
business strategy because we had
designed a website and very much we were
hunting for drudge links at that time
which was one way that conservatives
would
would try to generate traffic off of no
budget was if you get a link from drudge
it explodes your traffic
right and so we would try to get links
from drudge and we realized that
sometimes the gods were generous and
sometimes they were not
uh and uh and the other thing that that
we learned is that you have to
find you have to find an audience that
is capable of understanding that the
business pitch so well this is when you
gave me my nickname i believe
uh which is the stupid whisperer this is
because
you and i would always pitch people our
ideas and
you would come in and you would bend
shapiro all over them you would
use harvard words uh at 2x like
you are a podcast turned up to 2x just
in regular life you know in terms of the
speed of your
and and these people would just sort of
look at you with these blank
doe-eyed expressions and then the stupid
whisperer would come in
lilt yeah that texas stroller come out
real slow
sock puppets and i would explain your
ideas to them and they'd be like oh yeah
yeah
it was very frustrating i mean i
remember walking out being like i don't
understand they understand what he's
saying but they have no idea it was like
i was speaking swahili he's barely using
english they understand him they don't
understand anything but it turned out
that no matter whether it was
me or whether it was the stupid whisper
there are certain people who are just
not capable of
receiving these ideas and we both know
who we're talking about here
this is when you wrote our business plan
on a cocktail napkin
this is uh well now to be fair you came
up with a business plan so
jeremy was the one who who cracked the
code of not only
you know sort of we need to invest in
making people in our movement not just
me but generally
more famous we need to we need to
actually use the tools at our disposal
and you're the first person to really
discover the magic of social media and
how important social media was because
most of us were spending our days you
know
whittling away on twitter yeah but you
were the first person who said wait a
second there's a whole other world of
social media we really need to get
involved so
at this point you can take over the
narrative yeah i mean
the idea was we should be marketing
first right and social media presents
the opportunity to do that
and of course the freedom center and
therefore truth revolt were a non-profit
they were always struggling to figure
out how to pay for us because one of the
problems in conservative nonprofits
is that no matter how successful a
particular initiative
is its ultimate success is
determined by whether or not people will
keep giving you money for it and
unfortunately when you go to the same
donors year after year you have to give
them something new
so we had had a lot of success in that
first year or so of truth revolt
but what was the story we were going to
take to donors next and i said well
here's an idea instead of taking them
year after year what if we had kind of a
for-profit model within the non-profit
universe
where we could use ad revenue and the
enormous traffic available to us through
marketing on social
to pay for all of this and then we're
not beholden to the donors
and now even the stupid whisperer could
not talk slow enough
for for certain people to understand it
and we're in this big meeting one day
and this very wealthy
very elderly benefactor of of
conservative think tanks
said you know essentially he said i need
you to explain this to me in even
simpler terms and we'd explained it
about seven times around oh yeah
and ben turns over a cocktail napkin
takes a pin and you drew uh
an f for facebook well it was okay so it
was dollars
dollar sign okay arrow dollar sign arrow
f for facebook
for facebook arrow website arrow back to
dollar sign right and that was
that and i said this is our best this is
our business plan and yeah they fired us
yeah
they defunded us they fired you i quit
in solidarity that's fair they fired me
yeah well they still wanted me to stick
around so they could uh you know pretend
that i was still associated but i had
been
relegated off to the gulag somewhere you
know wasn't actually given the death
sentence i was just sort of cool and i
was like okay that's not what we're
doing
so instead funny thing is we both bought
houses like one month before this well i
mean it bodes very poorly for our move
because literally every time in our
careers we have bought houses something
cataclysmic has happened
that's like nearly almost immediately so
yeah at that point
we decided that we're going to take that
business plan and go to market yeah
and uh and you were really the driving
force here because you found that the
people who decided to actually take a
flyer on us
well our the third part of our triad
right caleb
our business partner co-ceo of the
company i've been working with caleb at
that time he he was working with a high
net worth family out of texas
and they're trying to get involved in
culture and like mark masters and many
others
before uh through whatever political
connections they got connected to me and
then i tried to talk them out of
spending their money on culture
because i wanted them to maintain some
of their money
and during this period of time i'd
really hit it off with caleb and
uh and when we lost that job at the
freedom center i i called him and said
listen i know you're trying to get
involved in culture
i said i think there is a path for
conservatives to create
entertainment but i think you have to go
the roundabout way i think
i basically gave him the same plan that
i had pitched to you and then to others
which was
we need a marketing mechanism a
marketing and distribution mechanism
that allows us to actually put an
audience on the target because hollywood
will never cooperate
even if you manage to make a great film
they'll never cooperate
they'll make it very difficult for you i
said i think with ben
and with what we've been doing at truth
revolt evolved with this cocktail napkin
business plan
that we can make something that's
capable of marketing
whatever we produce thereafter for for
this particular audience
and he got the vision right away thank
god because i don't know how we were
going to pair mortgages
you probably had some savings at that
time because you're
a more rational fellow than i am i had a
nicer car though
fortunately caleb quickly got the vision
and and he
and he went to the high net worth family
with whom he was working at that time
and and they took it they took a risk on
us
they gave us they committed to give us
seven and a half million dollars
to start the daily wire we didn't take
the money up front we didn't want it
that way we wanted
uh for them to just pay the expenses of
the company month after month up to the
seven and a half million dollar mark
and at month 14 we were 4.7 million
dollars
in and we became cash flow positive we
never took the rest of that money
and we've never gone back and taken any
money since i mean since then we've
grown this company
off of that cocktail napkin business
plan now it's
it's fair to say and i think caleb would
interrupt here if you were here and to
say
it got a little bit more sophisticated
than the cocktail napkin it did and it's
amazing when we look back at the
original projections which places we
thought would be centers of revenue
attracts places we did not so certain
places
that we thought would be centers of
revenue certainly our centers of revenue
but one area that we had no idea was
going to be a center of revenue was the
actual podcast revenue that's right like
when we
i look back at that business plan and
what we had allocated for the amount of
revenue from the podcast was
minimal compared to how successful the
podcast became so it just shows you you
know
all you can do is sort of plan for the
possibility of success and then you push
where there's actual
mush right you push you push where
there's actual give you know i i
responded to a tweet from
cernovich a few weeks ago he every now
and then when he
isn't posting politics he'll actually
post kind of aspirational business
uh ideas and and they're quite good i
can't remember exactly what he had
tweeted but it was something about
success and failure in business
and i responded with what i think is the
greatest lesson i've learned in this
journey that we've been on
which is that your success in business
ultimately it doesn't come down to the
quality of your plan
it doesn't come down to your ability to
avoid
catastrophe doesn't come down to your
ability
to systematize success all of those
things matter but
none of them are what determine
ultimately long-term success long-term
success in business
is just your ability to fail
maneuver and keep moving and that's what
we've really done over these last five
years i think that have allowed us to be
successful
we have ideas and they're good as far as
they're good they get you moving and
they get you pointed in a direction
but i think we've done a great job of
never falling so in love with our plans
that we're unable to change and maneuver
and pivot and shift
and you know let go of things that
i think people who fail in business just
can't let go of they can't let go of
their idea
they can't let go of their pet project
they can't let go of their ego
and so that's why i say you can't fall
in love with your pocket pair i always
say you can't fall in love with that
pocket pair because you don't know
what's going to be the the turn or the
river
and i think that that really is you know
as an executive which you now are right
you went from being a production guy
back when you were 17 to being an
executive so really the job hasn't
changed just the scope of the business
has changed
one of the things that i've seen in you
and i've told you this personally is the
amount of adaptability and growth
that you've personally gone through even
in the time when you've been running
this business is pretty incredible i
mean because we we started off
and it was okay we have this idea and
shockingly this idea is actually working
better than we thought this idea was
going to
and then you know there have been
periods where we hit real skids yes i
mean
there was one particular period not very
long ago you know within the last couple
of years
where we looked at each other and we
thought okay well we're going to have to
stick and move here because things have
changed pretty radically and i thought
that it was a
maybe you can talk about it because i
thought it was a real clarifying moment
for you as a as a person and as a boss
and as a person who helps
who runs a company yeah so
one of the things that people don't
understand there's a lot of things
and listen i was this guy you know i
grew up in a small town i had a huge
argument with with someone very
important to me
one time we were backpacking around
europe after after high school
and we got into an argument over whether
having a million dollars made you rich
keep in mind we're from this tiny town
right and
she had made this point that someone she
knows had basically inherited a million
dollars
and now they were rich and it never
occurred to me before that moment
that well if you have a million dollars
you have to live off of it for say the
next 20 years
it's only 50 000 a year right like
hardly rich
and so i argued that that wouldn't make
you rich and it's funny that
looking but when we were kids but this
became a major contentious issue
all that to say that until you've run a
business until you've
had to make a payroll until you've dealt
with large sums of money
you have a lot of notions about what
that would be that are you know like any
inexperienced person's notions are
probably
largely untrue the worst moment for our
business came when we were
the company was generating 28 29 million
dollars
that year and we almost lost the
business
you can say well how can you lose a
business that's making that much
money and it's because businesses
operate
on cash flow right how much money is
here at any given time
and like anybody's economics how much
money are you spending
and you know when you talk about margins
in business people
people get upset when they're like oh
you know uh
the ceo made a hundred million dollars
there's people who work for him that are
making minimum wage people who work for
him who are making fifty thousand
dollars
you know he could still make 20 million
dollars and he could give the other 80
million dollars to his employees
every everyone who doesn't know anything
about business or money has had that
thought
what you don't realize is well no if you
if you have
20 000 employees like these like guys
who are making that mcdonald's yeah
exactly
right that amount of money that you even
80 million dollars
they your employees wouldn't even notice
that they had gotten any extra money
when you divide it out across all those
uh all those employees
and you would have a worse executive
right you you wouldn't be able to get a
top level executive who can keep
who can keep growing the business the
the truth is
that as your company grows and your
expenses grow it only takes
one terrible moment cash is what makes
the gear it catches the lubricant
that keeps the gears turning and if you
run out of cash this thing locks up
it doesn't matter if you still have 20
million dollars of value
it doesn't even matter if you have 20
million dollars of revenue that would
come in over the next 12 months if you
kept operating
if you've run out of the cash necessary
to operate
the whole thing grinds to a halt and now
you can't get to next month where the
next
revenue would happen and you certainly
can't get to the month after that you
can't get to the month after that
that's why like when a company like and
i remember when kmart
went through bankruptcy they were
generating billions of dollars of
revenue at that time yeah literally
remington right now is going through a
bankruptcy because they cannot generate
enough money to generate enough guns to
sell
because people want to buy so many guns
that they literally don't have enough
money to produce the guns to sell them
because
even success can destroy a company
and what we were dealing with at that
moment is success was destroying our
company
it was destroying our company in a
couple of different ways one our
expenses
you know you spend into your growth you
hire new people
you hire you build new things and you're
kind of gambling a little bit because
you're banking on the rate of growth
continuing if it stops it seizes up
really quickly and one thing that
happened is our growth slowed down
and it took us a minute to realize it
and be able to adjust
our spending another thing that happens
in businesses
is you know i'd never run a business
with five people until we had five
people at truth revolt
and i'd never run a business with 15
people until we had 15 people
at the daily wire and i'd never run a
business with 25 people until we had 25
i'd never run a business with 115 people
until you know the other day
and you just don't know you don't know
what's required of you you don't know
what's required of the business you
don't know the new regulations that come
into effect you don't know how to manage
so in business you constantly have to be
replacing yourself
and what you find it seems obvious that
the things you're bad at
are problems for your business until you
replace yourself with someone who's
better at them
but the ultimate truth is that it's the
things that you're best at
that are the biggest threat to your
business because those are the things
that you'll
that you're the least likely to replace
yourself at
it's like i'm willing to hire an
accountant because i know i'm not good
at math
but it's very hard for me to hire the
people who are good at what i'm good at
and one of the great things that
happened during that period of
of real crisis in our company is that we
had already brought on
some very gifted people
and i think we had the humility in that
moment to promote them into
roles that formerly had just been me and
caleb essentially
and we we promoted them into the things
that we thought we were good at
and they were able to take the company
really to this whole next level
and it's the next area of growth for us
now now we're solving
not the current problems of the business
but it's allowed us as executives to
live in the future of the business
which is why we have the opportunity to
make this move that we're making is why
we have the opportunity
you know i don't want to talk about too
much of it here it's a little premature
but you and i both know that we're on
the verge of doing some things
that no conservative media company has
yet done some things that our audience
will in our movement will be
i think they'll be game changers that's
only happening because
because we hit those hard times and
because
like like struggle and failure always
are in life if you have even in
your personal life your business life
your spiritual life
if you have the humility to realize that
struggle is meant to teach you something
it's meant to change you
then you can avail yourself of the of it
as an opportunity because you can see
the hardship as an opportunity
i think that's what we were able to do
last year and why we're in this
unbelievable spot that we're in right
now as a company
so in a second i'm going to ask jeremy
about what the hell we're doing in
nashville like when are we going
how's this working what are our plans
but if you actually want to hear
our special super secret plans you have
to be a super secret top
level daily wire member head on over to
dailywire.com and click join at the top
of the page you can hear the rest
of our conversation over there well
jeremy it's good to see you i'll see you
in five minutes when we have a meeting
after this
and thanks so much for stopping by dude
yeah
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pablo wydowski
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva title
graphics are by cynthia angulo the ben
shapiro show sunday special is a daily
wire production
copyright daily wire 2020.